[Music]
today on stick to football it is time
baby here jumping in deep on the AFC
East not too deep mellow can't swim the
AFC East draft classes we're gonna break
those down starting with the Mughal
Patriots the defending champs don't
forget leave your draft on draft
questions if you're watching us in the
Bleacher Report app leave it a comment
or amazing producers are gonna go in
there check those out so fire the
comments that you fire it fire the
comments that you want the questions
that you want us to answer we'll do that
at the end of the show
Matt Mel O'Connor and yes I'm wearing a
t-shirt that says stick to football on
it they're making fun of me I think this
is like when you wear a Nickelback
t-shirt to a Nickelback concert Melo I
think we're a little bit better than
Nickelback but I said the Foo Fighters
it was like if Dave Grohl rolled out to
his concert he had a Foo Fighters shirt
on might be a little awkward but it
looks good thank you it's nice yeah we
get it Matt you're in the band but Melo
can you really not swim so I know
there's like a storm rolls in and there
I can you swim not good enough to save
myself no I can barely float I can
barely move so I just say no I cannot
swim I've been trying to teach him for
32 years I have no deal with my daughter
right now she's 7 years old and I'm
trying to get her to ride her bike and
she's like I will learn how to ride my
bike if you learn how to swim so
probably gonna die this summer but maybe
she'll learn how to read that bike all
right also follow us in the BR app
because you get more comments like the
fact that Melo can't swim and his
daughter doesn't know how to ride a bike
yet we hopes it will be hosted mailbags
we do it fun stuff all summer long so
make sure you follow us in the BR app
guys but we are going to break down
these draft classes today and we have to
start with the reigning AFC East
champion the New England Patriots and a
lot has changed since the last time we
saw this team Tom Brady is now in Tampa
Bay Rob Gronkowski is back from the WWE
but he's also in Tampa Bay and in a
draft that they had a ton of draft
capital what was your guys takeaway of
this class kind of your overarching
theme mellow will go to you first I
think with the Patriots it's just
business as usual the whole checks gonna
Belichick
now the guy loves to trade down he loves
to acquire more picks and he loves to
attack the middle of the field you look
at their draft class every single one of
these guys is in the middle of the field
we said they probably could use
a receiver didn't go after one thought
they might target a quarterback now the
role was my guy Jared Stidham no running
backs you stayed linebacker linebacker
edge and I even think he's gonna play
some linebacker too and then you get the
two tight ends and Kyle Duggar he's just
a do-it-all guy I think when you look at
Belichick and what he wants to do this
is gonna be his lawyer Milloy this is a
throwback player can be a badass at
safety but also probably come down in
the box and play a little bit of
linebacker when he needs to yeah listen
I look at the Patriots draft and know
I'd actually be curious how would you
grade that trap before I even begin oh
I'm gonna give it a C+
I like the draft I love this kid I don't
the door Ryan right here call it Kyle
Duggar but they didn't excite me there
are a lot of holes on this team they
needed to get some players out of this
draft and I don't feel like they did
they can't just sit back and say over
AFC East champions again they've got a
lot of making up to do because the team
we'll talk about next really did a good
job so I'm gonna roll the C+ for the
Patriots yeah I don't really differ that
much from you here when I look at the
New England rap there are things I
really like about it I think when you
look at the tight ends that's something
that excites me for their offense I
think it was not a strong tight end
class and they found two guys that have
more upside of the next level Devin a
COC is a guy that can work the seam I
thought he was a good athlete he seems
to catch everything at the next level I
think when you look at Dalton keen he's
kind of that guy that'll be a versatile
player he could work in the backfield I
thought he blocked actually very very
well but I see you see right here as you
see the seam the middle of the field as
you said Melo that's something that
they're always always going to work in
this offense and then when you get back
to the duggar pick I think that's
something that I had a problem with them
it felt like they missed out on Xavier
McKinney
I thought Antoine Winfield was a better
option I thought Ashton Davis and even
Grant Delpit were a little bit better
options but Dugger might have more
versatility so their draft was a C for
me because I don't know how much better
this roster got right now as much as I
like tight end picks and I'm just trying
to figure out the plan is the plan
really Jarrett Stidham are they going to
shock us and sign a Cam Newton because
that honestly that would scare me a lot
too I think Cam Newton in the Patriots
would be a really really good match for
the AFC East I'm just very confused
about the big picture here
I guess my big picture is that it is
Jarek Stidham I think the lack of
quarterback targets and I know Bill
Belichick said this wasn't necessarily
by design it was just the way the board
fell well they were in position to draft
you in love and didn't they were in a
position to draft any quarterback other
than Joe burrow twoa and Justin Herbert
so I think it is by design that you
didn't take a quarterback it felt like
all offseason that they're moving ahead
with Jared Stidham as the guy I liked
their picks you guys mentioned kind of
going deep while Kyle Duggar Devin is
CSC last time the Patriots had two very
good tight ends they had one of the best
offenses in the NFL because they were
dynamic they were versatile and I think
we see that again this year as they get
these two young guys into the mix so I'm
gonna give them a B so I get the high
grade for the New England Patriots but
Melo mentioned it your family i'm afaid
yeah I'm just close a fan
Melo mentioned the Bills of the team to
watch a playoff run last year a defense
that no one wanted to mess with a dual
threat quarterback and fellas they had
in my opinion a very good draft I'll let
you go first
again Melo what did you like about with
the books I think when you look at this
Bills team last year when we were doing
our team previews it's like oh god they
might have a team that can actually win
the AFC East and they got pretty damn
close and I love what they did in their
draft going after a guy well let's start
with the first pick they traded away and
they bring in a number one receiver you
needed a number one receiver they
secured a number one receiver and then
they bring in guys like AJ F Anessa
I really like what he's gonna do I think
that the edge rush position was kind of
sneaky you look at the roster and you
see some really good guys on there but I
think F and s that can come in and be
just a Swiss Army knife tool he can play
inside he can play outside I think he
can maybe even put his you know stand up
and be an outside rusher but then you
also you add depth but this defense is
gonna be scary
adding ed all of her last year and now
AJ F&S had to go with him he's already
battled with the big boys in the big tin
he can definitely do some damage in the
AFC East and then you get to the running
backs they added a lot of depth here to
this team but I think their depth pieces
that can come in and contribute Zach
Moss might not rush for 1,000 yards but
he might help Devin Singletary rushed
for a thousand yards
these guys are going to come in early
and contribute yeah this is yet another
draft class from Brandon bean that I'm
very very excited about but they did a
phenomenal job you say it off the top
you have to include Stefon Diggs
this class because they traded away that
first-rounder to get him they really
needed a wide receiver they went out and
got that they got a pro ready guy guy
that you already know as a star in this
league and then they were able to still
solve their other needs with value pick
so you looked at AJ F NS a-- of course
somebody that I think there's a high
floor player on the edge you'll stop the
run he has a lot of power to get himself
seven or eight sacks a year that was a
need but I look at Zack Moss as the pick
in this group that just makes the most
sense with the bills they have motor
Singletary there
he's a change of pace change of
direction kind of run around a really
good rookie season but you needed to
pair him with somebody that has some
straight downhill power and when you
watch Zack Moss he's somebody that
consistently created yards after contact
and we know this offense with three wide
receivers across the board that can play
and they did have Gabe Davis in Isaiah
Hodgins I was a big Hodgins fan but you
know this offense with the wide receiver
talent the offensive line talent to get
a power back in there it makes life a
lot easier for Josh Allen right now and
I think that is something the Bills have
done such a good job at this was an
a-minus class for me yet another good
year for Brandon being yeah I guess when
I look at the class I thought that this
is a tip which they're in the driver's
seat in the AFC East with Tom Brady out
of the division she's been out of the
conference now at Tampa Bay the Jets are
still rebuilding the Dolphins are
starting over the Bills have to feel
like all right it is our time we've
waited 20 years for this now it's our
time and it was safe pics like you guys
said using your first-round pick number
21 overall excuse me 23 overall and
getting a wide receiver except on digs
getting herself a playmaker approve a
playmaker but then you go get Gabe Davis
he's gonna start for this team
Isaiah Hodgins he might start with this
team I mean you're drafting high impact
very very safe picks so I am a huge fan
of what they did you all know if you
listen to this show watch the show
regularly I am a huge ajf in esse fan he
was one of my favorite players in the
entire draft I know there are questions
about athleticism I feel like Sean
McDermott is gonna know how to use a
japanesse I'm not worried about him
making a transition here at all and then
getting Jake Fromm in round five
even if he's only a high-level backup
long term then it's very smart with a
running quarterback in Josh Allen who
maybe is gonna get beat up a little bit
so I really like that pick light your
tables on fire they're gonna
day from me the bills did great can you
imagine going in practice you know and
when one rep you have Josh Allen
throwing you the ball and then there I
bring in the number tune it's it's gonna
be for me throwing the ball to Matt
throwing the ball there's gonna be a
world different it's like you got a
caller yeah here's a vehicle baller guys
try to hit it I don't think Melo can
compare himself to Josh on cuz he still
hasn't gotten the tattoo so until that
happens you have to shut your mouth all
right
today's show is sponsored by Jake from
State Farm not Jake from the Georgia
quarterback who slid all the way to
these Buffalo Bills in the fifth round
of the NFL Draft much like the constant
cuts to Jake Franz living room as he
realized he would not be drafted Friday
night
State Farm will be there for you through
good times and bad and just like Jake
from offers an entirely different skill
set from Josh Allen State Farm offers
both home and auto insurance when Josh
Allen misses a few players because he
runs like he is not six foot five Jake
from will be there to add relief and
when you need home and auto help Jake
from State Farm will be there to add the
same relief takes a farm thanks to State
Farm for supporting stick to football
that's what SS and there was what is
glad you doing I like the literation it
was a lot of s's I'll get better at it
all right speaking of s is the J ETS
there's this the Jets Jets Jets kind of
Rodgers favorite team they had an
interesting draft it started this is
what we wanted round four things got a
little bit weird Connor your grade and
your overall thoughts on the Jets draft
this year I actually thought Joe Douglas
did a really good job he got the most
value out of his trades he was able to
move back ten spots in the second round
and acquire plenty more picks guys even
a sixth rounder next year on top of all
the extra picks in the fourth round that
he was able to add this year you look at
this they needed a left tackle Makai
vecten was the guy for them Denzel Mims
they really needed a wide receiver with
size and speed that's a pick that I
think every Jets fan can be excited
about just with how poor the red zone
passing offense was last year and gives
us somebody that caught 12 touchdowns I
mean this guy right here though you
needed to get better on the ground
they had no space for levy on bail last
year George van't was penciled in as
their starting left tackle Makai pectin
is a big upgrade over that even with the
fact that he's gonna have to be coached
up to be more consistent in past
protection that's okay
but I look at this draft class as a
whole guy something that actually made
me pretty excited was to see Gregg
Williams who had a really good year last
year with not a ton of talent get a
voice in the room they took Ashton
Davison in the third round that's
assigned to me they want to be a more
aggressive unit they don't want to be a
cover to defense they want Ashton Davis
to play free safety eventually be a
single high guy let Jamal Adams run
around and make plays Jabari Zuniga it
wasn't my favorite pick in the draft but
they had no athleticism at the pass
rushers spots so for Gregg Williams a
guy that really got the team to seven
wins last year because the often
struggled under Adam GaSe I'm glad that
they gave him some help as well while
solving a lot of needs rome wasn't built
in a day but it's a b-plus for me
because I do think they got more pics
and addressed a lot of areas on the team
I like what they did I liked Sam darling
here's my core rec one in that class hey
I like that they're putting him as a
priority and say we need somebody to
protect you
and we're gonna give you some targets
I'm giving this draft ac because in the
hindsight I can look back and say I
could have CD lamb and Josh Jones or I
can have McKay Becton and Denzel Mims
and I just I like those picks better I
don't like Becton I gotta be it vocal
about it I don't know how good he's
gonna be so I really questioned that
pick and then taking a quarterback in
the fourth round I thought this was a
team with a lot of holes and I don't
know why you're drafting a player that
ideally won't play for you ideally you
keep him on the bench and he's in
meetings but he's never touching the
field to take a guy like that in a
fourth round and then the punter later
in the draft I'm giving this what a C I
didn't love the draft
I'm sorry Connor that is a grape yet
they drew up the great plant defense I
can't watch any other backup quarterback
that they were ready to roll out there
David Falls Luke Falk
I like James Morgan I know I'm biased on
that one it was earlier they had other
needs but man they needed somebody
behind Sam darn old he's missed time
over two years now guys it sucks to say
it but he has you know got to keep him
away from that motto bugs because
it hits everybody I'm sorry I brought up
punters my team doesn't need one so you
guys can take that you hit there's
retired that's how the Chiefs just don't
need a punter
all right when I look at the Jets class
I didn't like how they started it felt
like they just printed off the list of
team needs and Joe Douglas went okay
what do you love tackle got it
we need a receiver got it we need a
cover safety got it and they just they
stuck to the board which you're gonna
get a good grade from people like us
when you do that unless it's mellow
grading your team you were a Jets jacket
into the office today
by the way I've given up a c-plus
gentlemen and here's the reason I did
not love the player value with where
they took them I like the needs they
addressed I think it's a bard unique
Jabari Zuniga is a little bit of a reach
where they took him LaMichael P Ryan a
reach where they took him I think I saw
Connor tweet this as well this is a team
that they're really betting on bounce
back years for some players Bryce Hall
without that gruesome gruesome ankle
injury to the point that he was off some
teams Borg's they're betting hard that P
Ryan's getting it back to that 2018
downhill power run style the good news
is he's I'd be forced to action I'd
agree with y'all they had needs they
dress them I thought the value was a
little bit off that's why they get a
little bit lower grade for me all right
let's move on to the Miami Dolphin
O'Connor if you want to wrap up your
jets because when we got the Niners i'ma
going Rance so please I think it's fair
I think the two picks I really didn't
like where Zuniga and P Rhine
I just think big picture I'm glad they
got the left tackle they got a wife I
think that I gravitated to a player like
Denzel Mims at that spot of the draft so
I think we see a little different on
that one yeah alright how about the
Miami Dolphins they came into the
weekend with 14 selections the most of
any team they put out an elaborate
smokescreen they got me they got Vegas
they got Daniel Jeremiah milk I for
changed his damn mock Thursday morning
I'm still mad at you Mel so they got a
lot of people but what they did they
came over the quarterback in the future
and they protected him with their
offensive line picks Connor what were
your thoughts on the grade but then also
how they actually filled this roster I
really really liked it I mean right here
it was a b-plus trap for me just because
I was low on Austin Jackson actually
thought he was the top of third
player but in hindsight guys big picture
here you got to it absolutely love to a
think he's gonna be able to change the
Dolphins franchise I'd like to know it
but not gonna pick a lot when you look
at making me strength a bigger strength
they have three physical nasty corners
in a division where they should be able
to shut out passing attacks
Robert hunt was one of my guys so I
actually liked hunt better than Austin
Jackson I think what look at you see
Agron agony here so physical he presses
he plays the ball he's a Brian Flores
kind of player I think the Dolphins
overall did a really really good job
here I mean Brandon Jones is another guy
who's gonna come in play special teams
he could be a box safety for you I think
he can run with tight ends so I think
when you look at this overall I think
the Dolphins did a really really nice
job they played the draft very well by
not panicking and moving up and moving
around up to three where they would have
got played they knew to it was gonna
fall right into their lap so getting the
franchise quarterback getting some
pieces on defense and getting an
offensive line player and Robert hunt
and I think will be a very very good
guard at the next level gives this a B+
draft for me the AFC East besides New
England I really liked what the other
three teams did and I really like what
the Dolphins did here I'm gonna give
them a B+ they did they got all y'all
except for me and they got to it which
was their guy that I have may have won
it all along and I like I like their
played with two of though they went out
and they drafted some offensive linemen
Austin Jackson was probably a little bit
of a stretch their reach in the first
round but Robert hunt it's gonna be a
very good guard for this team it protect
this guy and then also continuing to
build up this defense you see that
Flores has brought over kind of that
Patriot mentality if we're just gonna
load up on defensive guys and I think
they're in a really great position this
year and next year they have two
first-round picks and they flashed some
Oregon offense on that screen and I
can't help but look at that left tackle
I think the Dolphins are really winning
this offseason you see I mean we can't
even fit all the pics on the graphic
here that they had they've really
improved this team drastically and very
quickly yeah that's what I look at guys
it's not only a great job getting to it
and not having to forfeit any of their
first-round picks in 2020 or 2022 they
come back loaded ready for next year but
to get it the quarterback that we all
love have you been healthy I think there
would have been a much
your debate about where he's stacked in
this class behind or even with or for
some people above Joe borough so to get
to it five is electric but this defense
is what I look at because I think to win
the AFC East you're gonna have to win on
the defensive side of the ball to bring
in Shaq Lawson and Emmanuel Aguas free
agents those are smart moves bringing a
land in Roberts Covino they know this
defense you bring in Byron Jones and
then you draft to supplement that with
Noah eggwin agony Raekwon Davis Brandon
Jones who's gonna play a ton of nickel
for them I got the Dolphins not to just
extend on their draft to the entire
offseason but man they had a great year
and beat Jones is gonna play all over
Texas fans know this dude from his
freshman year was rockin people on
special teams
he could play nickel coverage when I
talked to him before the draft he had
tore his labrum so he was out he made a
folder a binder on 32 teams have what
their defensive tendencies were how he
would fit in there
he played 80% of his snaps and man
converse in 2019 that versatility from
day three is really exciting for me so I
give the Miami Dolphins in a gray don't
forget y'all can leave your grades in
the comments below let us know why we
are wrong you can also if you're
listening to the podcast tweak those to
us just hashtag that Melo is always
wrong and we will read those comments no
you don't want to go there okay let's go
here then to a Belichick and Brady super
cut from our great friends a gridiron
Heights you see a tom is getting old and
needs extra protection well then apply
anti-aging organic I black made from the
ashes of Jimmy Garoppolo contract
extension Giselle was wrong one day I
will throw and catch the game light reps
for the normal players meditation for
Toms cold okay
thanks here's my special mind power Tom
the Patriots do not rebuild we reload
coach are we cool now
oh hi coach have you met our terrible
backup yet hello I'm Thomas whoops thank
goodness for the Tuck rule
Thanos didn't go far enough I collected
all six coach
we can finally retire now you gotta fill
this one I'll do it I'll move I don't
think about you as much as you think I
do
boy the Jets were tough I don't know how
we did it but yo if you're under someone
Sophia doesn't become an athlete video
we didn't even get to fully digest the
Tom Brady pillow cello Bill Belichick
break up and now it's already like Aaron
Rodgers hates Matt Lafleur we don't even
need football it's a soap opera we got
all the drama
any time Brady does something at Rodgers
just has to swoop in and try to steal
the Thunder right yeah date a supermodel
boom a NASCAR driver beat that all right
just can't beat him on the field tried
where his numbers didn't work all right
Dracula draft questions and don't forget
tomorrow we will be diving into the NFC
East so all those Giants fans who we
ripped last year when you took Daniel
Jones and Dexter Lawrence tomorrow maybe
we will try to make up for that maybe
but you have to be here at 5:00 p.m.
Eastern to find out if you still hate us
or not draft on draft questions though
still Mick rensil Berg which 2021 draft
prospects would you most like to play as
in the NCAA football video game that
they better be giving us or we are
writing I don't wanna speak for
everybody else but I've already made
signs and have pitchforks Melo who is
your 2021 prospect you want to play with
play as the most and fellas I don't
think we're getting this video game
anytime soon but if I can and I won it
I'm taking Justin field so Matt knows I
run the triple optionally better than
anybody runs the tricks got frost it's
very good and I've been just taking ass
with Justin fields I've got the updated
rosters on the NCAA 14 if you want to
play me we can make it happen
but Justin Fields is already unstoppable
in this game so that's who I'm going
with
yeah that's a great one because you
could run obviously you can throw it out
in the field I think the same could be
said for even Trevor Lawrence or I know
you guys really love trail and I look at
Jalen Waddell and the reason is maybe
the targets weren't always there last
year when you have two guys that were
first-round picks
playing in front of you
even to mom to Smith but when I look at
Waddell super super explosive I mean
that speed and acceleration would have
to be a 95 so he's somebody I'm excited
to see get a bigger target workload this
year and I feel like would be an
absolute cheat code in the NC Double A
game I got a story time I got to tell
you this I don't play a lot of video
games as you all know because I mean I
have kids and this job is busy so we go
playing CW 14 I haven't played it in six
years so I'm getting my ass whipped by
big country I booked Kerry Vincent jr.
and at quarterback for LSU and had one
of the most epic comebacks I've ever
seen at a football game
it was like Patriots coming back on the
Falcons so Karim is a junior you're my
guy even though you're not a quarterback
my real answer Trey Lance honey no
interceptions he rushed for 1,100 yards
and 14 touchdowns 28 to nothing
touchdown interception he's 6-3 to 21
this is like Michael Vick in the old
school Madden but real life so tre Lance
is my guy I like that pic and I'm very
excited about trail an see a lot of
people have been asking about him
because I Evan North Dakota State
quarterback who's a redshirt freshman
that I own is that good he is going to
be very good though all right next
question and our last question for today
Wyatt charter who was your biggest
faller factoring in landing spot so
bored versus where they went guys who's
your big baller
for me it's got to be Josh Jones I
really thought that he was going to go
18 overall to the Dolphins and these
slides all the way down the board
that wouldn't really surprise me I did
not think that he would fall out of the
first round but for him to do that was a
real shocker I think for me would have
to be a meek Robertson this is somebody
that I thought was a second-round rated
player now I knew he would fall a little
bit because teams boom has a slot corner
an undersized kind of guy but to fall
all the way to day three I think that's
absolutely insane and I think mike
Mayock is smiling now knowing the kind
of chess piece player he got for the
slot maybe they give him some reps at
free safety
the Raiders they're the ones that really
reap the rewards on that one I just
wonder how mike Mayock watched meek
Robertson because he only watches
Clemson and Alabama play probably
Louisiana Tech play clemson what
happened they barely got in their war
room yeah
right some mine would be Josh Jones or
exact bun they actually would be tied
excuse me because Zack Vaughn fell 274
overall I had him at 33 on the big board
and then Josh Jones who was 32 falls to
72 so about the same fall for both those
guys and I have heard that it's not
medical
there weren't issues just teams did not
think they were as good as we thought
they were so that is definitely a big
100 Bryant another one we mentioned a
lot on date through the trap I did hear
back from that it was medical reasons
just you try to dig into that this year
was a little bit more difficult because
there's just not a lot of information
flowing around from scout so you guys
excited for the NFC East tomorrow I am I
am I think
Cowboys fans are gonna be very excited
Cowboys fans are gonna be very excited
ego I can't wait they're Giants
bounce-back giraffe the Cowboys
beautiful draft I thought Washington did
pretty good obviously chase young but
even somebody you know like the running
back from Memphis that they got I think
when Antonio Gibson the Eagles we're
going to talk about those Eagles boys
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
fun tomorrow graves everywhere eagles
madness hashtagging cry Eagles cry we'll
be back to our finest on right here in
the Bleacher Report app Monday Wednesday
Thursday 5:00 a.m. Eastern Time
we'll see you all soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]